okay um good morning today uh we will do
gang Khan and the Mongolian Conquest now
um as you know the Mongols have a
terrible reputation for their
brutality uh for U their
atrocities um today I want to make the
argument to you that what they did um
given the circumstances
given uh the constraints they were under
was actually logical and understandable
okay so that's the argument I will make
to you uh
today all right so the Mongols um the
Mongols um as you know they are a step
people um the step um are divided into
the Western steps and the Eastern
steps um and they TR they basically go
from hungry in Europe all the way to uh
what is modern day
Mongolia and um as we discussed step
culture is very different from
agricultural culture that we find in um
in the lavant in Anatolia mes
Mesopotamia and in
China in the grasslands the economy is
what we call nomadic pastoral meaning
they will raise cattle as their source
of food and they will uh travel wherever
there is grassland okay so they and
because of their economy they have
developed a certain culture they are
extremely uh violent um their society
their culture is based around
violence and um there's a lot of
competition uh Within These certain
groups so um rather than think of these
people as a as a um Nation or race of
people it's better to think of them as a
culture okay and for the longest time
throughout human history they have been
divided among many different uh
tribes throughout human history the
nomadic pastoral people of the steps
have always been in conflict with the
agricultural Empires
um so in response the AG agricultural
Empires China and the Persians they have
built walls and and
fortifications to counter their threat
okay so as you can see the U Mongols
will eventually come South and invade
most of China um and historically the
response has been the Great Wall of of
China okay um but also in Central Asia
the step people have been a threat as
well and they have built fortified
cities as a as
response okay so even
though the step people and their
agricultural empires have always been in
Conflict the Mongols have had a unique
reputation in Western history as the
most brutal as the most um as the most
violent okay so the question we're
looking at today is why were the Mongols
unique in their brutality okay so
um um there are lots of things that were
said about the Mongols that we now know
today were are not true okay so for
example back in the day um they had a
reputation for cannibalism um they ate
their opponents they ate their enemies
and we know that's not true today they
also had a reputation for being devious
so for example um when they approach an
enemy they would hold the cross okay the
cross is is a symbol of Christianity so
their Christian enemies would see this
and think that they are
allies okay and only when they
discovered that these are actually
Mongols um but by then it was much too
late okay so the Mongols had a
reputation for being extremely uh
devious um they had a reputation for
wanting brutality they would destroy
entire cities and kill all the people um
um previously historians believe they
killed about 65 million people um to
today that figure is disputed okay but
but if that but if that was the case
then the Mongols killed more people than
any other regime in uh human history
before the 20th
century um Daniel con is considered the
greatest conqueror in human history so
uh the the statistic that surprised
everyone is one out of 200 males today
um they are a direct descendant of
gangas Khan so that's that's like 16
million people okay 16 million males in
the world are direct descendants of um
Gus Khan right so that is the reputation
that the Mongols had for most of History
and what I want to show you today is the
Mongols are not unique among the steps
people okay and the way they behaved uh
there was a um strategy there's a logic
to the way they behaved given the
circumstances and constraints they found
themselves um under okay so um as you
know in this class the step people were
the greatest conquerors in human history
okay so they started with the yaya who
um were based in the Ukraine area and we
know the yaya who who are also referred
to as the Proto Indo Europeans as well
as the Aryans okay they spread
throughout uh most of the western world
so they went to Europe um and as we as
you know they basically replaced entire
male population of Europe and they
intermar with the local woman to create
um European culture they also went um
South and conquered um Iran and India
and then they went over to the uh
Eastern steps as well so it's really
important for us to remember and I I I
know this is hard but the Mongol people
they are culturally more similar to the
um uh yamaya than they are to the
Chinese even though genetically uh the
Mongols may be more similar to the
Chinese okay in this class we focus on
cultural values rather than genetic
Affinity okay so um over time what will
happen to the Western steps is it will
slowly acclimatize itself to the
surrounding
agricultural um Empires and slowly the
Western steps will become integrated
into
the um the the agricultural into their
agricultural neighbors so the example
here is cfia okay so cfia is slowly um
it's it's an Empire it's a step Empire
but slowly it's about to integrate
itself into what is modern day Eurasia
okay um from the from the cians you
you'll have arise something called the
median Empire which will then give way
to the Persian Empire
over in the Eastern steps okay the um
the step people come into conflict with
the Han Dynasty and the Han Dynasty as
we know from last class is really the
last ethnically Chinese dynasty and they
are intent on um a policy of eradication
against the step people so they come in
conflict with the step people who are
now called the Shu okay and what this
conflict will do is drive these people
West okay and this is interesting for us
because when they go west they will
Splinter off into different groups when
they go all the way to Europe they will
be known as the Huns okay you may know
Atilla the Hun well Atilla hun is what
what's the leader of these people the
Huns will drive um the the Western step
people meaning the gos into the Roman
Empire causing conflict with the Roman
Empire okay and the goes will become the
foundation of modern day
Europeans um
okay so this is the hunt Empire at its
peak when it's in conflict with the uh
Roman
Empire um the step people the Huns will
also give rise to um a bill called the
gurk Empire okay and and they will sweep
down and they will become the suic Turks
uh which will um take over Mesopotamia
and then eventually you will have uh
emerged the Ottoman Empire from these
people right so in other words the
Mongol are
just um the most successful iteration of
the step people and their conflicts with
the agricultural uh Empires so the
Mongol Empire is the second largest
empire ever in human history only the
British
Empire um had more land the Mongols were
the largest
contiguous Empire meaning meaning it was
all it was all interconnected together
all
right um at its height the Mongol Empire
extended from basically what is modern
day Russia all the way to China okay the
um the Empire that will take over the
Mongols centuries later is the Russian
Empire okay the Russian Empire will take
over a lot of Mongol uh
territory um because it is so large um
after the death of gangas Khan and his
son uh agade the Mong Empire will
Splinter
into four
major um Empires okay and these four ma
major Empires themselves will assimilate
and integrate into the local culture um
the golden horde will will eventually
give rise to um the Russian
Empire um the UN Dynasty will eventually
fall and give rise to the Ming Empire
okay so even though they conquer a lot
of territory um ultimately their empire
is not sustainable and later on I will
explain to you why it was not
sustainable and why ultimately ly the
Mongol Empire
declined but while it was still uh in
place it created something called the
Pax mongolica okay this is Latin for the
Mongol peace uh you've heard of the Pax
Romana we are now living in the Pax
Americana okay so the Mongols created
something called the Pax uh Monaga which
is meant they believed in globalization
they wanted their conquered Nations to
trade with each other because they could
CL they could collect taxes on the trade
and they encouraged people especially
Merchants to um travel across their
empire and trade with each other and
during this time a very famous um
Italian Nam Marco Polo had a chance to
visit the world um and his travels
especially um uh those to China capture
the imagination of Europeans this is
really the first time that China figured
into the European imagination okay so
this is a map of um maro's
travels okay and as you can see he
basically traveled all across the
PX uh Mongol Lea okay the problem though
is that when you integrate the war like
this you also give rise to disease so
the black death um traveled all across
the world okay so we believe the Black
Death originated in Central Asia in in
in a place we we call C kazakistan today
and it traveled all over uh the Mongol
Empire uh it made its way to Europe and
it devastated Europe okay it killed um
anywhere between a third to half of the
entire population of
Europe it traveled also to uh the former
Islamic empire and it traveled to China
but it was not as devastating okay it's
very important for us to understand the
black de was devastating for Europe but
it was not that devastating for China
and the Islamic empire and the reason
why is sanitation and hygiene so in
China and in in the former Islamic
empire uh their cities were pretty well
organized pretty wealthy pretty
civilized but in
Europe um their streets were literally
filled with manure okay they had horses
they didn't have sanitation people just
threw um onto the streets and so
like when you walk the streets they were
literally covered with and in that
sort of environment uh disease is spread
very rapidly but the Black Death is
important for us also because it will
give rise to the Renaissance which we'll
do next week okay so about the Black
Death historians believe the Renaissance
could not have happened uh the Black
Death basically meant a reset of
European society and it allowed um
massive innovation in
Europe okay so as you can see the Black
Death was extremely devastating for
Europe
um um after the Mongols will come
another great conqueror called Timmer
the lane Timber Lane and he will be the
last great conqueror from the steps
after T after timin the agricultural
Empires will develop the technology to
repel the SE Invaders mainly gunpowder
okay uh the
technology and mass armies will
overwhelm the step people and eventually
um over time the agricultural Nations
mainly Russia will start to colonize and
conquer the
steps
right okay so look let's look at today
at GS Khan who is the founder of the uh
Mongol Empire okay
um M gangs Khan will you first of all
unite the Waring tribes of the Mongol
people he'll turn them into a
Confederation and then the Confederation
will aim to conquer China but then it
will come into conflict with the Central
Asian Nations and so um gas Khan will
embark on the Central Asian campaigns
that are brutal he'll wipe out entire
cities he'll he'll kill all the kill all
in inhabitants he will lay the
foundation for the Mongol conquest uh
that will follow after
him okay and again um after the death of
his son oade the Mongols were split into
four major factions and they will
attempt to continue the legacy of
Conquest but what happened is after they
conquer the S Empire in 1279 they will
attempt to conquer uh Japan and Vietnam
and when they try to do so they will be
repelled they try to conquer Japan twice
um and even though the legend is that
Japan was saved by the kamakazi right
the great divine wind um I will show you
that's actually not true um there's
another reason why the Mongols sto
invading uh Japan so in the East they
they've reached the limit of their
Conquest um they tried to conquer India
as well but when they tried to do so
they were repelled and historians argue
about the reason why this why this is
the case some believe it was because of
the climate of India some believe it was
because of some because the uh Southern
of Delhi um had a organized and
concerned response some other believe it
was just internal fighting
okay when they tried to reach Europe
they
will um try to conquer Poland and
Hungary and even though they win every
single battle against the poles and
hungarians they will ultimately turn
back and and that and that will be the
limit of their Conquest in the west so
the
um um Mongolian fighting style is great
when you fight in flat planes okay these
are Horsemen with bows okay so um
they're fast they can cover great great
distances but when when when they try to
reach Europe and Europe is thick forest
right they really can't conquer that
terrain one really stunning event is
when they triy to conquer Egypt remember
Egypt for the longest time was the
wealthiest part of the Western World
when they try to conquer Egypt they run
into a people called the mamluks who
fight very similarly to the uh Mongols
in fact the the M the Mooks originally
from the steps as well and for the first
time
uh the Mongols will be defeated
militarily on the battlefield and this
sort of destroys the aura of
inevitability and invincibility that the
Mongols had for the longest time okay
and this will be the extent of their um
Conquest in the west and after these
conquests the Mongol Empire will try to
rule their respective um Empires But
ultimately they will fail okay and later
on I'll explain to you why they were
doomed to fail and the irony is the
reasons that gave rise to the Empire are
also reasons why the their empire
ultimately collapsed
okay okay so I want to first talk about
gang Khan and so we don't know much
about gang Khan what we do know comes
from a book called The Secret history of
the Mongols so it is a um oral history
of The Life and Times of gas Khan and
his son oade right now um the story in
the secret history is suspicious and
it's suspicious because it fits very
well into the structure of Proto inder
European myth all right so so let me
show you how it's similar okay in the
secret history gas KH
um his mother um and and you know again
they are in the molan grasslands his
mother is about to be wet to her husband
so she's in her carriage and she's along
her along the way to her husband's tribe
but along the way she is ambushed and
kidnapped that's a very common thing in
that culture the way that you obtain a
wife is by stealing someone else's wife
uh and so she she's forced to marry a
stranger um but the stranger gangs
Khan's eventual father dies when Ghan is
8 years old when the father dies the
tribe abandons the mother and her young
children so they're forced to offend for
themselves um
eventually uh the mother finds a way to
find a supporting tribe and gets g con
slowly finds mentors for
protection um
he eventually finds a mentor who becomes
his best friend and this friend best
friend's name is jamoka okay and and the
two together um are great warriors and
they conquer a lot of territory Terror
together in fact when gas Khan's wife is
stolen by a tribe the two will race off
and get the wife back um but by this
time uh gas Khan's wife is pregnant with
another man's son gas
raised the son as his own and he made
the son here to his Empire which will
cause great difficulties when gangas
Khan dies okay but that just shows you
the generosity um of this man eventually
gangas Khan will run into conflict with
jamoka and the two are competing for
control of the Mongol World gas Khan
kills him to um achieve his
dominance and um um G Khan will
overthrow the existing Mongolian social
order basically all these top Chieftains
all these top shamans he will kill in
order to unite the Mongol people and
bring about a new social order okay so
that's the story that we we have from
the secret history and that's very
similar by the way to other U founding
myths of other people like for example
let's look at Rome okay so um remember
last semester we discussed virtues in
the
okay and it's about the founder of Rome
his name is enas enas is a prince of
Troy and he has to watch the destruction
of Troy he escapes the he escapes the
sacking of Troy where everyone is killed
but he gets lost at sea okay eventually
he um stumbles under Carthage where he
falls in love with a queen there named
ditto but the God's the man that he
leave he leaves D the woman that he
loves and he's married and he does he
betrays ditto who then kills herself
then he goes to Italy where he has to
fight a war in order to establish the
children people uh on Italy and they
will eventually give rise to the Roman
people okay so it's so it's a very
similar structure the story of gangs
Khan let's go to another story uh from
Rome so the founder of Rome is named
ramulus who was direct descendant of
inas um so two so there's a king uh um
called n numor and his brother amelus
USS the throne and once amelus USPS a
throne he puts uh num's daughter into a
temple and makes her a virgin okay but
Mars the the war guard Mars visits her
and impregnants her with twins numer
demands the twins be killed and the
twins are left alone by the um Tyber
River okay and everyone thinks that they
will drown but they are miraculously
saved and a She Wolf nurses them and a
Shepherd adopts them eventually they
discover their true Heritage and they
help their grandfather numerator um kill
um his brother amas and restore the
throne then the two go off to found
their their own city which is Rome okay
but there's going to be one king so the
two fight and Romus kills his twin
brother
Remis all
right and then Romus becomes Rome's
first king which will eventually give
rise to the greatest Empire in the
European world all right so as you can
see the structures are very similar so
let's go over very quickly the structure
and meaning of Proto Indo European myth
the thing I want to remember is that
what mythology ultimately is it's a
collective
subconscious of a culture okay by
understanding mythology we can
understand the fundamental values that
underpin this culture so what is the
structure we're looking at okay the
structure is this first the God's favor
of man with a Divine Mission but the man
himself does not understand this Divine
Mission okay the gods have picked this
man for whatever reason this man must
fulfill his Divine
Mission and in the process he will
suffer hardship to become as hard as a
sword okay hardship makes you committed
it makes you strong and to recognize his
mission okay in the process he's asking
he's asking himself why am I being
persecuted why am I suffing so much and
then eventually he will he will have an
epiy he will recognize oh it's because
the gods have a mission for me that I
must fulfill that's why I'm that's why
I'm suffering that's why I'm being
persecuted it's to make me strong and
committed okay and he will sacrifice his
beloved love to prove his commitment to
his Divine Mission okay this is really
important in Proto Indo European myth
the hero must always sacrifice his
beloved so remember the story of gangas
Khan he sacrifices he kills his best
friend jamoka okay and you think okay
what's a big deal well in that culture
when tour are best
friends they're not just friends okay
they're basically
lovers they have sex with each other and
that's why uh they're such great
Warriors together it's a very common
thing so remember the Iliad where uh in
the ilad hector kills Petrus and
achilles um becomes so inrage that he
goes and kills Hector okay so um why did
Achilles become sore in Rage because
Petrus was his best friend which at that
time every everyone understood to mean
Petras and achilles were
lovers okay Achilles loved
Petrus so when G Khan killed jamaka he
was basically killing the man he loved
the most in this world okay that's a
very important part of portal endur
European myth you have to show your
commitment by making the ultimate
sacrifice which means killing the person
you love the most and once he does that
he will Shadow the old world to build a
new one okay that is divine Mission the
gods do not like this world they want a
flood to destroy this world in order for
the world to be made a new and this man
the Messiah he is the one who will
shatter the old world he's the world
shatterer okay he is the flood sent by
the gods all right so that's a basic
structure of Proto indoeuropean myth and
we and when we understand this now what
we can do is understand the power of the
Jesus story within Christianity
why is Christianity the most uh
influential and popular religion in the
world it has to do with the story of
Jesus
okay in the story of Jesus according to
the gospel of Mark let's look at the
structure okay it's very similar to
portal Indo-European mythology Jesus has
a secret Divine Mission okay he's sent
by God or he is god um come who's come
to redeem the world he must s suffer
persecution and doubt okay so everyone
doubts who he is no one knows who he is
he's laughed at he's mocked okay he then
is sacrificed to wake the world he kills
himself or he is sacrificed so that
everyone
knows how much God loves them and with
God sacrifice the cycle of violence ends
and a new history begins okay so in
Proto Indo European myth what's
important is that you kill your beloved
but the founding myth of Christianity is
no I kill myself to show you that
violence is
terrible okay once God has killed
himself once God has sacrificed himself
it means that all violence now must
cease the cycle of violence the cycle of
using violence to redeem the world to
cleanse the world must come to an
end okay and that's the very idea
foundational idea of Christianity and so
what Christianity is doing it's very
clever is it's seeking the collective
subconscious that's embedded in every
individual and imp planting a new idea
within the subconscious that grows and
grows okay it's almost like a virus
until people recognize that violence is
bad protal Indo-European mythology
celebrates violence right
Christianity um belce violence is the
worst thing okay so so so let's um sorry
um this is a bit okay all right anyway
I'll I'll I'll just read it to you okay
so this is the ending of Mark okay then
Jesus gave a loud cry and breath his
laughs okay so he's been sacrificed he's
died and the curtain of the temple was
torn into from top to bottom the temple
is the temp second temple in Jerusalem
where Yahweh is and at the very top of
this Temple is a room called the holy of
the holies that's where God lives and
the curtain is what um
hides uh God from the world okay so when
Jesus dies the curtain now is torn in
half meaning God is now released into
the world which mean which means that
everyone now has access to God God is
now on Earth okay now when the Centurion
the soldier who stood facing him saw
that in this way he breed his last he
said truly this man was God's son so the
first person that Jes Jesus revealed
himself
to was a Roman soldier the first person
that recognized the truth of Jesus and
the power of His sacrifice was a Roman
soldier who's always been taught that
violence is the answer to everything and
once he's converted he re he he
recognizes that violence is wrong and
evil okay so that's a power of um this
mythology okay does that make sense for
you guys all right so now I want to look
at real history okay because this is
mythology and what I want to do now is
show you that gas Khan fits into the a
pattern of a great conqueror if you look
at all the great conquerors of human
history and I'll list four right now
okay s of Aid Philip of Mason Julius
Caesar and gas Khan you will see they
are very very similar okay so let's get
S Arad remember um
before in Mes in Mesopotamia it was
divided into the Samaran city states
that wared with each other and these
these were walled cities because these
were walled cities they couldn't really
conquer each other okay s of aad figured
out a way to conquer everyone and build
the first Empire in world history called
the Acadian Empire so we don't know much
about him but this is what we know first
of all he was probably a mercenary okay
it's very common back then um to be a
mercenary because the city states were
at war with with each other always he
was a cup Bearer to the king or Zaba of
Kish Kish is one of the city states in
Samaria now guys cup Bearer is a very
important position a cup Bearer means
that when you're at the king and you
have a feast and a or a festival for
your people the cup beer is a man who
stands beside you and pours you the
alcohol the wine right which means this
is the man you trust the most so what
does it mean for S aad to be a cup
Bearer well it probably means that they
were lovers the king and Sargon were
lovers who loved each other deeply okay
but that doesn't prevent Sargon from
killing the King and taking the throne
which starts this massive war in the
city states in which um Saron will
eventually Triumph
okay um well so the thing about Sargon
is he is really good
at uh winning the favor of mentors right
and ultimately he will betray mentors in
order to achieve his ambition well
that's also true for Philip of Macedon
so um Philip of Macedon he is a prince
of
Macedon and at this time in the Greek
World thieves was a dominant military
power thieves defeated maedon in a
battle and thieves demanded hostages so
Philip was sent as a hostage to thieves
where he is now mentored by the greatest
military strategist all this time named
IIM my noce okay and so Philip II is
learning how to win battles he's
learning all the major military
innovations of this time from the
greatest general of this time and then
what he will do is he will return to
Macedon reorganize the Macedon Army and
then take them to conquer thieves as
well as the entire uh Greek world at the
Battle of Shia okay
well this pattern is also true for
Julius Caesar in this at this time which
about like 50 uh BCE in Rome pompe the
great is the greatest General he's the
man that everyone admires he has most
Bal power so what julus Caesar does is
he's he marries his daughter to pomp the
great and this forms a polical alliance
between the two pomp the great grants
him um generalship of the province of
Gul where Julius Caesar will win
military Glory okay it basically
establishes the power Prestige and fame
of Julius Caesar and this will start a
Civil War in which um Julius Caesar will
defeat his mentor Pompei at the Battle
of
farcas okay very similar pattern well
the same is also true for gangas Khan he
is mentored by two Chieftain jamaka and
too and he will defeat both in order to
gain leadership of the Mongol world so
it shows you how ruthless and ambitious
these great Congress are but at the same
time let's remember this Philip II had a
really talented subordinate in parmenion
parmenion was really uh the person in
charge of the Macedon Army in fact it
was penan who was most responsible for
ACC the great conquest of Persia okay uh
Julius the Julius Caesar had a talent
sub subordinate in Titus lainus who was
responsible for his victories in Gul and
then gas Khan had a talent subordinate
in superai who was considered one of the
greatest military strategist um ever
okay and so what this tells us
is they're able to have they're able to
exercise tremendous judgment in people
they know who to trust they know who not
to trust they know who is talented and
who is not talented they know how to how
to win the loyal
of the subordinates okay that's a very
impressive skill and then the question
then is how is it possible that they are
ruthlessly ambitious at the same time
they're able to delegate power in a very
effective Manner and the answer is they
all believe they have a Divine Mission
their goal is not to conquer the world
their goal is to change the world for
the better as demanded by the gods does
that make sense that's the only way we
can understand this each in their own
way believe they are the Messiah sent by
the gods to Shadow the world so that so
that it can be built a
new okay and that's what drives them to
kill their beloved and that's what
drives them
to um um do what they do okay um all
four ultimately they are able to conquer
the world because they develop a
professional meritocratic and Innovative
Army okay what does professional mean it
means that look at Saron the great a
Saron of akid at this time there were no
professional
soldiers um most people were farmers and
you only fought off season okay you
might fight two three months of the year
sgon of aad um was the first to say nope
we will have professional soldiers
everyone else will pay taxes in order
for me to uh pay my professional Army
but these are professional soldiers they
are
full-time um soldiers at War okay uh
meritocratic means the system before was
the nobility always had a priority the
nobility was always right and a s of aad
made the system more open and fair and
mraic so if you were talented and you
were Brave you could rise within the
ranks of the army regardless of your
heritage um and your background
Innovative means they were always
adapting and learning so s Aid was able
to conquer the subaran city states which
again were walled by adopting Siege
Warfare which was unheard of before okay
and the same is true for Phillip Julius
Caesar and gangas Khan right so again
gangas Khan fits into a pattern here of
what these great conquerors look like
does this make sense to you guys
any
questions so
far all right let's
continue okay so um now I want to
discuss why the Mongol did what they did
okay why do the Mongols commit so many
atrocities what was the logic or
reasoning behind their brutality all
right all right in order for for me to
do so I'm going to introduce you to you
today a new an analytical model called
Game Theory okay the idea of game theory
is this all human reaction can be
perceived as a game in which two people
at least two people are playing and
they're trying to to defeat each other
okay so if example let's just say you
know um these two guys
are um fighting each other okay they
want to kill each
other now according to Game Theory each
person has a distinctive optimal
strategy okay it's called optimal
strategy optimal strategy is given the
constraints of your
circumstance what is the best way for
you to win okay so if you're the big guy
okay this is the big guy he wants the
game to be fair which is like let's just
arrange
to fight at a certain time and we'll
fight okay and he and he he wants to uh
use this strategy because he is most
likely to win but if you're this guy a
small guy right let's call him a and
you're fighting B you don't want to do
that because you're bound to lose so
what you do is you figure out a time
when uh be is most vulnerable maybe when
he's asleep or he's eating and you
attack him then okay you basically have
to cheat in order to win so each
individual has a distinctive optimal
strategy all right now this sounds easy
but it's not because often there are
multiple players in the game okay so you
have C and you have D and when when you
have multiple players in the game you
have to think about about alliances in
coordination okay so it's possible that
A and D will form Alliance to attack B
which will force B and C to form an
alliance okay but once maybe um C and B
kill off d then a and c will form a
lines to kill off B okay so what this
tells us is not only does each person
have an optimal strategy given the
constraints um of the game but this op
strategy will change according to the
circumstances all right also what's
important for us to remember is that
there are there always these
external um constraints
external constraints might be just
weather or weapons or whatever okay so
Game Theory sounds easy but it's
extremely complicated because you always
have to switch perspective in order to
better understand why this person is
doing what he or she is doing okay does
that make sense all right
so let's look at um Game Theory and
apply it to the Mongols okay remember
the Mongols are a Borderland people and
they're fighting Empires and remember
with you if you're Borderland okay
Borderland
Empire you have three distinct
advantages okay you have
energy um you're open and you're
opportunistic okay these are the three
advantages that you have as a Borderland
people like the Mongols as an Empire
your feor advantages are mass you have a
lot of people you have organization
you have death okay so um it
seems so so again given the strengths it
is not that um easy to determine who
will win okay but we're trying to figure
out the mentality of the Mongols okay we
know the Mongols have these three
strings and they're trying to defeat the
Empire which has these three strings at
the same time we have to remember the
among themselves have three fundamental
weaknesses that they must compensate for
if they are to win okay so let's go over
their major constraints the first
constraint that they have is extremely
low
population okay there are not that many
of them in fact they're often outnumber
often 100 to1 and so that's a major
constraint um at when when g tom was
alive at his height he had anywhere
between 100,000 100,000 to 200,000
troops okay
okay the second constraint
is the idea of distance and geography
what I mean by that is the
Mongols have to fight over huge
territory because Central Asia Asia is a
huge uh land right and this is
problematic because of supply issues
supplies what this means is if you are
the Mongols the thing that you cannot
ever fight is a war of
attrition a war of attrition just
means a long war in which in which
you're trying to deplete the other
person's resources if you're the if
you're the Mongol the worst thing that
can ever happen to you is if you're
stuck in a war of attrition if the siege
is too long or the war lasts for too
long okay because eventually you'll run
out
soldiers so that's what the Mongols fear
the most okay so distance the last thing
this is really important is
governance governance just means the
Mongols are nomadic people who do not
know how to govern other people so they
don't be stuck in a situation where
they're forced to govern other people
okay does that make sense and what this
means is the idea of whole
territory when you conquer a new land
what you usually do is you put in place
a new regime they can't do that because
they don't have the Personnel for that
okay they often don't even have the
personnel for Siege Warfare but what
they will do is recruit Chinese
Engineers um Indian engineers in in
order to implement Siege Warfare okay
but bureaucrats are very hard to um
compensate for okay so these are three
fundamental weaknesses of the Mongol
system low population they have to fight
uh long distances and therefore they
have have to worry about supplies and
they don't know how to govern other
people okay and if we do this okay if we
look at what the strengths are and we
look at what their fundamental
constraints are then we can figure out
what their optimal strategy is
okay so this is the optimal strategy for
the
Mongols the first is escalation
dominance
okay escalation dominance is this okay
there there's a concept um in political
science called es escalation
ladder the escal escalation ladder I
mean it's a very simple concept it means
like violence always escalates so for
example um I get into an argument with
someone okay well what first happens is
we start to argue but then eventually
this argument becomes more much more
heated we start to push each other okay
then then I might throw a punch he
throws a punch back then I might bite
him he might bite me back um I might
pull out a knife he might pull a gun
okay this called
escalation ladder okay violence has to
happen over time
okay and this is fine if this is fine
but the problem is what if you're
fighting multiple people at once right
so what you want to do is show other
people that you are more dominant okay
so if you insult me I'll put a gun on
you and I'll shoot you okay that's the
idea of escalation dominance I always
have the
capacity to inflict more damage on you
than you could ever possibly inflict on
me okay and that's
why the Mongols did what they did so
what what what often happen is the
Mongols would send um a trade delegation
to an Nation to negotiate a trade deal
and the nation um Pro usually in Central
Asia um they would kill all the
delegation in order to insult gas Khan
in response genas Khan would send his
army to destroy the entire city burn
down the city and kill everyone okay
this is the idea of escalation dominance
you have to prove escalation dominance
if you are to um to be a viable threat
to everyone okay so that's the first
idea escalation dominance second idea is
the idea of
Terror or what we call psychological
warfare if you are badly outnumbered in
Warfare then you have you have to make
people afraid to fight you okay if you
cannot govern people if you don't know
how to properly manage people you have
to make people afraid to Rebel Okay so
the Mongols were notorious for
psychological warfare so for example
what they would do is this they would
conquer some territory and to ensure the
villagers would not ever Rebel they
would send one Mongol Soldier into the
village okay this is one soldier and
there might be a thousand villagers and
then what this Mongol Soldier will do is
randomly kill some villagers he'll say
hey you guys come over here line up and
he starts killing people randomly okay
and if the villagers ever
Rebel and kill him then the Mongol will
come and kill everyone in the village
all right so that's the idea of Psych
psychological warfare but the Mongol do
this do this to do this to themselves as
well okay so the Mongols have a system
where units are divided into units of 10
okay so 10
soldiers um and then these 10 soldiers
times 10 will make up a unit so what
would happen is this if ever in a battle
um one soldier
ran away from Battle all of the people
in these units would be um executed okay
but if if one unit ever ran away then
the next unit 100 of them would all be
executed okay so this gives everyone
incentive to make
sure your fellow Soldier does not run
away okay so the Mongols had
psychological warfare not just for other
people but also for themselves that's
just the way the Mongols fought and they
had to fight like this given the fact
they were great
outnumbered and they had to win quickly
against
their um
enemies right does that make
sense okay and the last thing which is
the most important is they had to create
an
aura of
inability and
invincibility at this time time people
were literally telling people these
Mongols are not human they are demons
they have come from Tartus and and
that's where where we get the name
Tartus they have come from tartous hell
in order to kill everyone okay these are
demons guess what guys the Mongols
wanted this reputation okay they
everything they could in order to
promote this reputation because it gave
them an aura of inevitability and
invincibility they could not be defeated
there's no point in trying to defeat
them so let's just give up okay and most
did most said like the Mongols were able
to conquer so much Terror so fast
because they had this Aura of inability
and invincibility and most people just
gave up they just PID tribute if you
didn't do so then they would use
escalation dominance and Terror to um
kill everyone
okay and they would send refugees all
around the world so everyone would know
about the ferocity and brutality of the
Mongols okay does that make sense guys
so in another words I had to say this
but according to Game Theory everything
the Mongols did made
complete uh sense okay in fact it's
their optimal strategy okay given the
circumstances given the constraints what
they did was completely logical and
reasonable even though it resulted in
the deaths of of T tens of millions of
people okay does that make
sense all
right okay so then so now let's discuss
why their Empire
collapsed all right so there's a
fundamental weakness in the entire
Mongol optimal strategy approach it's a
great strategy if you are trying to
conquer the people but when you're
trying to govern them okay it's an issue
all right
so um as we
discussed the Mongols are great
warriors uh like all step people because
of their cultural values this is a
culture okay that emphasizes three
things first is
freedom second is egalitarianism
okay and the third is self-reliance
okay so rather than think of the Mongol
the Army as a Empire or organization
it's more like a confederation people
choose to join this confederation
because of the immense rewards that can
be achieved through Conquest okay um so
this is a culture that values freedom
egalitarianism and self-reliance and
therefore it makes great
warriors the problem though is the
cultures they conquer were
extremely extreme
hierarchies all right where you have
maybe the emperor at the top a
bureaucracy and then peasantry at the
very bottom so the vast majority were
peasants okay now um I know this is hard
for us to understand but the reason why
the Mongols were able to conquer these
Empires
were almost a
contempt for these Empires does that
make sense guys the Mong AB no respect
for these Empires they thought they were
weak they thought they were corrupt and
um decadent okay so so the Mongols were
able to conquer them okay does that make
sense there's a contempt for them the
contempt is
this the M underlying the optimal
strategy of the Mongols is a concept
that never existed in human history
before and the concept is
this
people are an infinite
resource okay so throughout most of
human history people were the most
valuable resource there wasn't that many
of people around therefore you have to
treat people nicely if you want to
maximize their
productivity
okay but where were the Mongols based
they were based in East Asia they were
based in China basically and in China
because of the Empire people were
treated like an infinite
resource you could Massacre them you
could send them off in human W attacks
it didn't matter because they were an
infinite resource and this idea never
existed before in human history and in
the Western World this concept is
radically
revolutionary it was UN imagable like
you could do this so remember Julius
Caesar even though he um when he
conquered
Rome he wasn't intent on masing people
why because people could be sold as
slaves that was the main way he made his
fortune by selling the GS as
slaves right but if you believe that
people are an infinite
resource then you don't want them as
slaves okay you want you want to kill as
many people as possible in order to
inflict
Terror okay so that that's the issue
with the Mongols first of all their
value system did not lend itself to um
governing a hierarchy they didn't know
how to and they didn't want to also much
more problematic was their contempt for
the local
culture okay if you have contempt for
local culture you're going to have
problems managing the people so in China
during the UN
the Chinese um there's a class system
the Mongols were at the top and the uh
Chinese were at the very bottom okay the
foreigners were sort of in
between and that just shows you the
Mongol contempt for for Chinese people
and that's why ultimately uh the Chinese
people rebelled against the
Mongols right now eventually the Mongol
leadership would
recognize this problem and they were try
to adopt um a Chinese style bureaucracy
but a bureaucracy and we discussed this
comes into conflict with the
nobility okay nobility the nobility is
intent on maintaining the Mongolian
culture they do not want to assimilate
but the emperor recognized you have to
assimilate if you are to have this
Empire and because they couldn't agree
the nobility and the emperor couldn't
agree ultimately it led to the collapse
of the Mongol Empire okay
all
right so that's the history of the
Mongols any comments any
questions I I I I know Doug is can you I
don't have any questions yet though but
but but but do do you want do you want
make a comment because I I know you've
stud the Mongols quite in in detail I'm
kind of scared this is on YouTube it
okay okay all right yeah all right so
yeah it's
fine okay any questions guys like I know
this there's a lot to take take in so um
you know ask questions tell me where
areas you are confused
by okay I got I I got a question okay so
so a few lessons ago yep
you talked about if there was a a viking
University you would definitely want to
go to that yeah right because like in
the Viking world you it's all about
Freedom equality and self reliance right
yeah so the Vikings might be running
harder but uh um the Mongol University
might be be the Oxford yeah yeah got
any any sympathies one way yeah that's a
great question okay that's a great
question Vikings versus Mongols okay
um okay all right
so
um the Vikings and the Mongols all come
from the Proto Indo-European culture
what we know about culture is that it's
very fluid and it will change over time
and it will adapt itself to the local
cultures okay and so the Vikings were in
Europe
and the Mongols are near China
okay and
um I have to
say like um I
think if I wanted to be a viking or
Mongol I prefer to be a viking
okay and the reason why is the Vikings
never
really um adopted a belief that people
were an infinite resource they couldn't
because Europe was very poor um and the
Vikings regardless even though they were
brutal they still had respect for their
opponents they never developed a
contempt for their opponents they're
surrounded by the byzantines the Muslims
and the Europeans and these were great
warriors so the Vikings felt they had a
lot to learn from these cultures and in
fact ultimately the Vikings will
assimilate themselves into these
cultures in different environments okay
so um um um the Mongols are different
though the Mongols are based in East
Asia and they did ultimately adopt a
belief that people are an infinite
resource and they had tremendous
contempt for Chinese culture okay and um
that changes you as a person when you
believe that um people are infinite
resource and you are contemptuous of
other
cultures it also in a
way um makes you contemptuous of
yourself if that makes any sense okay um
and so ultimately that's why the Mongols
were not able
to uh even though they had tremendous
wealth they didn't really
produce um cultural monuments we don't
have like like the Vikings I mean as I
mentioned the Vikings were fundamental
development of Western Civilization the
Mongols were not fundamental development
of any civilization I mean they caused a
lot of havoc and they were great
conquerors but they didn't leave a rich
cultural Legacy so and I I think I think
it has to do with the belief like people
are an infinite resource okay um so I
would PR much prefer to be a viking I I
would much prefer to be enslaved by a
viking than than than a Mongol like like
if I I if I were a slave I would R much
rather be a slave to a viking than a
Mongol okay if I were a slave to a
viking the Vikings would at least become
my friend they'd be like hey tell me
about your culture are there any stories
that you can tell us okay and if you a
great Storyteller then they would make
you um they would treat you very very
nicely because because you're helping
them learn more about your culture okay
the M have absolutely no interest in
other cultures they're interested in
conquering and exploiting other people
all right I could be wrong all right and
and I'm probably making these crash
generalizations but I believe with the
Vikings there's a gener curiosity about
the world that comes from a general
respect of other cultures whereas the
Mongols were not curious about the world
they were intent on conquest and
enslaving other people and exploiting
other people okay they were predators
and again um that could be my Prejudice
but but based on my readings so far that
that would be my um uh belief but please
change my
mind sounds good sounds good okay all
right thanks for the question okay great
great question and any other question
or or or or sorry sorry so population
okay so the Mongol population is Loosely
defined okay do you understand uh it's
it's hard to say who's Mongol and who's
not Mongol because that that entire area
has a similar culture and it's it's very
hard to figure out where the where the
borders are okay
like
yeah okay great question okay yeah so
you're right so the Mongols
are um a low population so why would
they believe that people are infinite
resource the answer is because they are
always in contact with China okay so the
Mongol were always in contact with China
and as and as I mentioned they're all
the interaction happens in three ways
okay the Mongols are working as either
mercenaries for dynasties in China or
they are trading okay or they're raiding
and pillaging okay so uh for centuries
there's been contact between China and
the Mongols so where did the Mongols
learn the idea that people are infinite
resource well they learn it from China
right and and why why why they learn
from China because Chinese Warfare was
also predicated on the belief that
people were an infinite resource does
that make sense so B basically the
entire um idea of warfare in China is I
organize this presentant Army I throw
throw on my opponent okay and if my
entire Army dies guess what I'll just go
and I'll raise another pres Army and for
my opponent again okay it's it's it's
it's it's like human WF attacks okay we
call this human Waf attacks this was
this was pioneering in China okay and
the Mongol just took it and used it
everywhere
else right so if you're if you're the
Mongols and you're used and you're
fighting this enemy and they're just
fting these peasant at you and you're
killing them all but they don't no one
cares because because then like a month
later another pres Army comes at you
okay you quickly adopt the idea like
people are infinite
resource right does that make
sense I think they were also
pretty not the right word were pretty
loose in terms of like who could be a or
not so it could absorb different
populations
that's right yeah
depends that's right um yeah the Mongols
um were very open Society like like if
you had a benefit to their society and
so for example if you're a Chinese
teacher or a Chinese scholar or a
Chinese
engineer or a Chinese Merchant they
would quickly assimilate you okay um and
then they would kill everyone else
okay so um they're a pretty open Society
okay so so does that make sense okay
great any more
questions
yes okay great okay all right so let's
talk about mythology right so again if
you actually studying
mythology what you recognize is there's
a structure that's very similar across
many different cultures right so if you
look at Greek if you look at
Roman uh
Norse
Mongolian okay I I could go on and on
and
on
um there is a very similar structure
even though the characters might be
different okay but but but it's it's a
mythology that celebrates violence and
individualism
um as a way to remake the world okay
it's upate strength individualism
violence so why is that the case and
it's it's about culture cultural
values so um as as I discuss in this
class culture cultural values are the
most persistent part of who you are why
because it's part of your subconscious
okay there's a conscious
you and there's a subconscious
and ultimately you are your subconscious
and subconscious is composed of your
cultural values okay this is the essence
of who you are so even though the portal
Indo Europeans they were going into
different environments and they were
assimilating themselves into different
environments and they look physically
different culturally subconsciously they
shared a similar value system and this
value system will then go on to inform
the way they perceive the world their
worldview and this worldview will then
man man manifest itself through
mythology which will eventually become
literature okay okay does that make
sense so they might have changed
clothes um they might have changed the
hair color but their soul was still
Proto indoeuropean okay and the same the
same is also true for language and
that's
why um and that's why so many words um
repeat themselves in different languages
okay
okay all right does that make sense okay
great any more
questions okay all right okay great so
um next class we will go back to Europe
we will do the Crusades which will then
take us to the Renaissance and the
reformation and the C Revolution okay